bienvenue à tous dans ce petit blog en
guadeloupe ses faux seins et vos
montages regardez je suis dans mon
studio
franchement un enfant de 8 ans avec un
fond vert forêt des blagues meilleur que
moi mais c'est pas grave on va fermer
les yeux les amis aujourd'hui on va
réaliser un rêve
cette vidéo aller pour l'enfant l'enfant
que j'étais il ya quelques années
l'enfant qui jouait à counter-strike à
longueur de journée et qui essayait
d'être le dernier en vie sur de dust2
les vrais savent l'enfant qui se disait
mais peut-être que dans dix vingt ans
quand on jouera on sera vraiment dans le
jeu et ma les amis je crois que le futur
était arrivé parce que c'est possible
via une pâle copie russe de counter
strike qui s'appelle pavlov sauf que
c'est en réalité virtuelle et c'est
vraiment les mêmes maps les mêmes armes
tout pareil ce très bien plus ça nous
permet de faire un peu de cas vie alors
est-ce qu'on va aller voir et
développeur de jeux en leur disant ouais
vous avez compté compte faire ça avec
vous abusez pas du tout merci les devs
j'ai toujours voulu plonger dans les
malles de counter-strike chaque
bouteille est copié alice alors comment
ça marche ok comme ça ensuite parce
qu'il faut apprendre c'est à dire qu'on
va devoir tout faire nous-mêmes
ok il faut la chercher
c'est incroyable comme enjeu on fait
à fois pillée hockey au wahoo à nos
gamins c'est vraiment c'est fou paper
oui selena mais pour moi c'est
incroyable c'est le futur
wafo touche vraiment à une grenade
comment ça marche des grenades à sanaa
est périlleux alors rejoint une gamme
sans plus tarder jouer en ligne 2 de
certaines des citoyens à temps c'est à
dire qu'on a qu'une vie je vais tomber
avec des pros et aya des français c'est
bien ça généralement ce midi salamix mi6
là à banos on apprend ainsi que
l'indiqué au [ __ ]
olala aux mecs c'est fou et iphone os
you my friend
waouh au commencement charge non
malfrats je vais pas sous la voûte servi
aux eaux non monsieur pour charger
pourra changer manuellement
ouais je sais quand tu es trop gentil
avait été trop mignon je t'aime jason
katims vas-y vas-y on va faire des
interventions à deux on va tout [ __ ]
mon pote tu es en amour tiens je te
donne la mienne ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas jouer à counter bien mais qu'un
méfait les travers attention à toi sois
charge
attention pas à givet au couteau
[Musique]
je vais me faire je lui fais pas
d'accord si je marche ça tire pas droit
du coup faut que je m'arrête pour tirer
en fait pas les gages que j'ai relu
hochstatt arabe j'en ai lu un g tu es un
mec gétules harnais avec regarder cette
phrase prenez du recul c'est glauque je
vais pas aller sur un serveur hôte que
ça parce que c'est trop galère va
répartir et salue au nom il était trop
mignon mais en fait c'est une game ou
respawn pas et moi faut que je prenne et
contrôler au moins là je suis trop
mauvais attendez je vais me former je
vais me former et où est une caisse
partie
[Musique]
c'est bon malgré cet incident alors je
suis prêt chiens entraînés alors on a
joué en 1e c'est parti au présent ok ok
ok c'est chacun pour soi
c'est chacun pour soi bien mec là
incroyable à moi incroyable d'un coup
avec jasmin à temps mais attends attends
on est où là
ça les gars suivant 18 commencer
l'entraînement entraînements non mais
bien en fait faut connaître comment
recharger la veille à plein d'un
différente si super du hockey mais que
cette fois je m'intéresse à tabac au nom
non ils sont partout non c'est abusé non
ils sont partout vraiment quoi c'est
impossible il faut avoir faim service
militaire pour être bon on situe
actuellement dans les garde temps légal
à attécoubé le vrai je suis là povtyp
attention parce que vous êtes prêts à
voir le mouv le plus petit du monde
il est trop fort
ouah
quel duel de coûts moi je vais attendre
j'attends l'âge mari john o tu la
parcelle à mon petit pote pardon [ __ ]
mais c'est tellement dur des fêtes
d'accord ça vous fait donc je suis
combien j'ai fait c'est ce qu'il est je
suis pas dégueu mais qu'étant mais il ya
des pros regarder à des pros de ouf
mais je suis en train de kiffer j'ai
besoin d'être en 2030 la surcroît
yannick tient le couteau un couteau au
chic à saint lô
je suis sur une série non aux mecs
désolé je crie ma seule manière des pma
joie et crié mais je vais aller comme ça
en fait ça ne marche pas du tout je me
suis emporté au delà il arrive
selinger saleya jeu suivant
je connais pas bien la longueur ne
m'embrasses un problème que j'ai dans la
vie c'est compliqué bon alors j'aime
bien cette note met en cause les trop
les uns sur les autres puis à des mecs
qui torchent la map depuis 22 jours donc
avant on va arrêter les bêtises on va
rejoindre game où on est un peu moins
collé de toute évidence je vais gerber
c'est évident au cénacle tarder ces
nocturnes en version un peu cheap mais
bon ça reste le tarn
allez on y va
oh là là comme si trop chaud
dans les tapis sentiers
[Musique]
attends attends attends attends
merde
[Musique]
hu
c'est trop dur voulais pas faire un team
deathmatch sur de dust2 et on se met
ensemble magnum donc vas-y est entre
gens allaient être que je me suis fait
des pâtes sûr je m'attache écoutant je
vais jouer avec deux français on
recherche une instruction ça veut dire
qu'on a qu'une vie donc falloir jouer
bien quoi
vas-y j'apprends maire va s'éprendre
apprend là je sais pas moi c'est les
gants passion à tous je vous suis là je
vous suis mais t'inquiète vous couvre 1
je suis un bon gars le café avec la ola
chaumeil pas aimé la bombe et la banque
moderne ouvert douze derniers mois
attends je te couches est ce que je me
ménage
j'ai mis deux bombes attendez moi est ce
moi prendre son art à lui la tempe
rebond des commandes mais là elle est
passée du gravier pas pris la bonne
on va lesquels les gars ben ali khan on
est la meilleure squattant le taux
d'impôt qui arrive ok ok voilà au oui
oui et tendez bon les gars oui bon ok
les gars super moi vous en faites pas je
suis en plein de mecs à temps passe de
vente est pas et se vante d'être quand
même juste one way comme ce symbole
chinois non pas du tout c'est pas pour
ça c'est que je veux montrer aux gens
comme d'efforts et omnia personnes alors
on y va
[Musique]
non ok on y va [ __ ] quelle lourde
perte sensible mais la bombe et la bombe
et la bombe chez maladroite au il était
caché le bâtard [ __ ] je vais la voir
simon un contre un le monde me regarde
oh non non et à lui mon pote je vais
poser avant que j'aie faire honneur
montage et faire honneur en pâte
mais comment poser à bout merde j'ai
fait n'importe quoi j'ai où on va aller
contourner venait comme on va les
comptes on aimerait contrôler les gardes
et voilà les parties basses de mossoul
avait pas d'armes
oui à tanger rabat c'est un truc à temps
c'est bon je laisse donc derrière
non non et nous baise la gale la attends
tu sais quoi les gars je vais y aller au
couteau hockey vas-y vas-y les gars
attirer les laissez moi passer devant
j'ai un couteau laissez-moi y en a j'y
vais
aujourd'hui j'en ai eu un [ __ ] ça
c'est mes années c est ce qu ils
reviennent ça le skill et revient petit
à petit on le voit pas demain parce
d'avoir fortement passe devant je te
convergent découvert personne personne
on avance mais ils sont pas la solution
mais non mais t'es mauvais là bien joué
at war le commerce c'est qu'on va te
conduire chargé watts et sean hayes five
ah merde et bonnec moi les gars là je
vous jure je fais un vestiaire des biens
j'ai la puissance au moral à l'aide que
les familles aient parfois à droite
là il y en a un là
j'ai eu ou pas non il faudra non [ __ ]
c'est chaud la censure bb&t suez détient
oui l'équipe qui gagne
aulas lors des shows l'égard des amis
1h40 de réalité virtuelle ces genres 9
heures de jeu sur le pc alors qu'à ce
que ray de réalité virtuelle
je suis dans un malaise tu es dans ton
jacuzzi je suis dans mon envie de vomir
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
désolé c'était un peu le cafouillage
mais j'avais pas jouer avant de avant la
vidéo et mec j'ai une jet roger une
gerbe et je suis blanc et je pus en plus
de ça c'est ça l'avenir du jeu vidéo ces
êtres couleurs pour ça il s'en tire très
fort la sueur
c'était quand même cool de tester ça
avec vous merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
on se retrouve très vite dans une
prochaine portez vous bien à très vite
je vais direct ou check up
merci que le mort j'ai plus qu'à y aller
ici maintenant
[Musique]